i just want to bring you some breaking  news regarding the incident in norway  yesterday the shooting incident uh  suspect with a bow and arrow that attack  taking place in norway in kongsberg  while norwegian media are now naming the  suspect of that bow and arrow attack he  has been named as 37 year old espen  anderson broughton  four women and one man were killed  during this shooting spree a police  officer  among others were left injured the  latest we have from the security agency  in the country is that the attack  appears to be an act of terrorism but uh  norwegian media releasing this image and  the name of the suspect  37 year old espen anderson broughton  more details as and when we get them  here on sky news